[Musique]
jean luc barek bonjour alors on sait
déjà rencontrées pour si on parle et on
a un petit peu évoqué ce lieu votre
arrivée ici mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
questions à vous poser d'abord ça fait
vingt ans on avait dit que vous êtes ici
comment vous avez qu'est ce qui est
voulu et qu'est ce qui a changé dans
votre métier en 20 ans ou alors c'est
une question extrêmement intéressante
beaucoup de choses ont changé dans nos
métiers en 20 ans et on peut dire que
une véritable révolution se passe depuis
cinq ans à peu près je vais vous donner
2 2 3 chiffres qui me paraissent
révélateur de cette différence de mode
de fonctionnement de la restauration
il y a 20 ans quand nous avons créé
cette entreprise et jusqu'à il ya dix
ans à peu près donc vous voyez 91 2001
nous étions dans un restaurant dit
d'affaires 1 les hommes d'affaires
venait ici à partir de 12h 12h30
d'autres stands me dit oui il restait
jusqu'à 15h30 16h
on y prenaient l'apéritif des bons vins
et un digestif un bon cigare et dont
deux venus dans wii c'était enfin la
restauration de cette nature est un lieu
de convivialité de rencontre acer aussi
la con déclenchait un contrat c'est
qu'on récompense est un contrat et le
soir ou le week-end les fêtes de famille
était très en longueur c'était normal à
l'époque de prendre une entrée une
deuxième entrée un poisson une viande
il y avait entre temps le petit l'origan
oui mais c'était ça dans les années 90
et jusqu'au début des années 2000 et
puis petit à petit les choses se sont
accélérées
parce que premièrement dans les
entreprises il a fallu serrer les
boulons
il ya un certain nombre de crises ont
été déclenchées à partir de des années
2000 qui se sont en plus aggravé donc
les entreprises ont réduit l esclave
budget on a été plus attentif à sa santé
alors par contrainte ou par nature par
nature et bien on a fait attention à
moins manger à manger plus
par contre juste non parce que l'on
traque au 9 mai à mouillart à moins
fumer en fait voir maintenant à ne plus
fumer du tout donc voyez tout ça a tout
changé à modifier les comportements de
nos clients ajoutez y le fait que et
bien par nature on est aussi sollicité
par et quantité d'autres choses à toulon
aujourd'hui à le portable le web
bientôt ça vous savez vous qui aviez
sage et oui bien dans son portable sur
la tête et puis ce qui fait qu consacre
moins de torre pas et quand on dit qu'on
consacre moins de ton repas on n'en
consacre moins au restaurant habits 10
c'est un phénomène évident quand on
avait largement deux heures pour
déjeuner il ya dix ans aujourd'hui on y
passe qu'une heure on s'est dit qu'on a
diminué le temps par deux et cette
habitude du déjeuner c'est aussi une
finalement transmise au dîner au dîner
on n'aime pas attendre
et même si on traîne pas et on n'aime
pas que le repas très long on veut bien
traîner après le repas le soir pour
discuter non mais on veut pas attendre
ne va pas attendre qu'on prenne la
commande donc le mode de comportement a
vraiment considérément évoluer ce qui a
évidemment sa pêche en jus retrouvé
complètement notre métier en plus
très honnêtement on s'aperçoit même dans
la très grande restauration que les
choses un petit peu compliqué ce qu'on
appelle à l'aide le 6 6
on en veut plus quoi voilà et donc vous
allez une simplification d'une
simplification on a abandonné maintenant
bal des ego en page plus efficace va
être plus efficaces nos cinq sens tout
ça oui oui alors il n'y a pas que du bon
dans tout ça mais bon nous avons plaisir
quand même moyen mais en même temps que
celle le plaisir et on le sent bien à
l'égard du comportement de nos clients
six attendent de trop ils ont - ils
veulent pas attendre ils sont impatients
par contre à partir du moment où ils ont
été satisfaits
gustativement par le cadre par
l'efficacité et la gentillesse du
service par l'addition qui ne doit pas
aller trop élevé eh bien ils repartent
contents et nous avons nous alors yens
oui on a avec les additions un petit
flyer qui après merci que les gens
peuvent remplir ayant le sommes très
attentifs aux commentaires que laisse
nos clients bon heureusement les
présentait plutôt très positif vraiment
justement qu'est-ce que vous êtes aussi
responsable syndical pour voler les
restaurateurs vous voilà ont déjà une
période compliquée du chômage mais on
dit toujours qu'il y avait des
une profession dans lequel est difficile
de trouver des employés est ce que la
restauration la restauration est très
touchée par ces difficultés de
recrutement pour deux dans l'ordre il
est très précis en termes de chiffres
dans l'ensemble des métiers de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie mais
l'hôtellerie moins nombreux ils ont
touché mais quand même la restauration
il ya beaucoup de restaurants avec la
français environ 110 mille entreprises
en restauration dont 80 mille
entreprises qui servent leurs clients à
table dont environ 20000 restaurant qui
peuvent prétendre être des restaurants
dits traditionnels et sur ses vingt
mille entreprises dites traditionnelles
environ 4000 sont classés dans les
guides et 24 seulement ont trois étoiles
au guide michelin
ça c'est pour vous donner une idée
d'installer la mise à la pyramide mais
actuellement dans notre secteur
d'activité quarante mille postes ne sont
pas pourvus faute de la landi un emploi
absolument actuellement à paris intra
muros la statistique de pôle emploi
c'est que il y a deux postes vacants
pour un seul candidat
alors comme on explique ça alors ça
s'explique de façon assez confuse mais
je dois dire qu'il n'ya pas une seule
réponse il ya le même problème à peu
près dans l'ensemble des métiers dits
métiers de bouche ou boulangerie
pâtisserie charcuterie boucherie etc
il ya aussi ces problèmes dans le
bâtiment aussi dans la grande
distribution
alors ça sera chez lui je dirais à deux
choses essentielles
la première c'est la pénibilité mon et
pas dans le job très facile ça nécessite
quand même une bonne santé et de la
dépense physique
bon ça c'est la première un métier dur
ton métier du mois de mai c'est vrai
faut être présent il faut être en forme
cependant il est clair que dans le cas
de l'abbé six nations
l'association falcon 9 heures non c'est
entre 9h et 13h est objectivement qui
suit responsabilité pour le domaine de
l'hôtellerie pour l'ile-de-france pour
les indépendances s'appelle d'ailleurs
bonbons syndicats c'est la confération
confédération des professionnels
indépendants de ses péages c'est le
deuxième syndicat français après l'umih
dont le président andré daguin fut
l'origan le père 13 objets charismatique
il a été parmi ceux qui ont vraiment
bien bagarré pour obtenir la réduction
des coûts de revient donc la pénibilité
c'est un métier physique c'est assez
difficile
et puis aussi les contraintes n'ont pas
de temps de travail ou durée du travail
ne le fait que nous travaillons au soir
oui le samedi 8 10 fera-t-il les
salaires sont plutôt de bons salaires le
smic hôtelier est le smic plus élevé de
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité en
france
bon mais pour autant c'est vrai que à
une différence de 150 200 ou 300 euros
et bien beaucoup de jeunes s'affairent
avoir une vie de famille équilibrée
plutôt que travailler le soir ou le
week-end nous avons beaucoup ces
contraintes chez nous alors en même
temps faut bien rester ouverts
les week-ends parce que nous avons
beaucoup de monde le week end ou soir
aussi beaucoup de monde le soir alors ça
pose évidemment quelques problèmes alors
à nous de mobiliser quand même nos
troupes de les motiver de faire on sent
sa part dont ça a toujours été le cas ça
la difficulté de trouver des employés
pour 6 ans et c'est pas nouveau mais le
phénomène s'est accéléré parce que il y
a de moins en moins de candidats à la
formation bon parce qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de demandes dans d'autres
secteurs d'activité qui recrutent
beaucoup les services mais aussi les
domaines financiers ça peut être pas
durer
enfin ils recrutent encore pas mal et
dans les secteurs industriel et je dois
dire que d'ailleurs la politique qui
semble être foulard mené par tous les
partis aujourd'hui qui est de règle du
strictly musées de france
ce qui évidemment à dix pendant le dîner
risser va aussi faire qu'il y aura
beaucoup de créations d'emplois dans ce
domaine industriel et nous dans nos
domaines à nous on aura de plus en plus
de difficulté donc à nous de faire en
sorte de de motiver nos troupes il ya
des moyens pour le faire et ça commence
dès l'apprentissage alors il faut
améliorer l'apprentissage faut le rendre
plus qu'en cordon avec les contraintes
de l'entreprise
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je ne le dis
pas pour fâcher nos amis formateur mais
c'est vrai que dans les lycées hôteliers
dans les centres de formation
d'apprentis là ce qu'on appelle les
référentiels de formation sont
déconnectés de la rétro souvent de la
réalité rhin de ce nom ne vous reste
bien très gros efforts
nos organisations professionnelles et
s'en occuper c'est très compliqué et
puis bon usage de l'argent l'idée de
l'asra leur métier il faut en même temps
aller vite et en même temps on est en
face de grosses machines quand on est
par exemple on passe dans l'éducation
nationale il est clair que c'est pas
vrai ce ne seront pas d'un claquement de
doigts mais en même temps tout ça évolue
bien
un hameau sur la sur la tva la tva a été
objectivement ça crée des emplois remise
à niveau je dirais sur le plan de la
fiscalité entre les entreprises qui
faisaient de la restauration à emporter
et celle seine furieuses de la
restauration servie à table
scandaleux score vous aviez un
restaurant où vous serviez vos clients à
table avec du miel pour ça vous payer
une taxe à 19 6 % que quand vous donnez
un bateau dans la nature ou dans une
telle disparité fiscal qui a été réglé
est-ce que ça a créé de l'emploi
oui un peu mais vous avez constaté comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure que
nous sommes quand même en pénurie de
candidats
bon donc il n'y a pas assez de candidats
pour les postes à pouvoir il manque 40
mille aujourd'hui candidats pour des
postes qui sont pas pourvus dans
l'ensemble du territoire français pour
autant ça a permis quand même de donner
une mutuelle à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs de la restauration et de
l'hôtellerie s'étaient pas le cadre de
la restauration à table c'est la
restauration qui est tout c'est
seulement ça a permis de donner des
primes tva à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs qui avaient plus d'un an
d'ancienneté dans des étangs des
entreprises ça a permis quand même de
mieux rémunéré et de mieux encourager
nos colloques socialement c'est et oui
là les progrès spectaculaires et on n'a
pas assez parlé dans la presse et c'est
bien dommage un dernier mot parce qu'il
va falloir société malheureusement mais
quand vous regardez puisque vous avez de
cette vision globalité de la profession
comment quelqu'un va venir vous le voyez
écouter un avenir brillant avec deux
raisons fondamentales le premier la
première raison c'est que le nombre de
repas 10 hors domicile continue
d'évoluer
ça veut dire que les gens en province
comme en ville à la campagne comme dans
les centres urbains mangent de plus en
plus à l'extérieur de la maison
c'est un phénomène qui perdure depuis
une bonne dizaine aime et qui continue à
creuser fortement donc la restauration à
deux jours devant elle par contre la
restauration dans sa globalité doit
tenir compte des nouvelles contraintes
de temps et de moyens de ses clients
donc là dessus il ya des progrès à faire
les cartes aussi doivent s'y adapter on
a parlé à quelques reprises ensemble ils
rencontraient des produits sous produits
surgelés et c est bien et il va falloir
que les restaurateurs ça à ce que tout
ça va se mixer sur les cartes des
restaurants
il faut bien sûr défendre la qualité et
la sécurité
mais en même temps il faut aussi
défendre le temps de travail de nos
collaborateurs et le bien-être dans un
cadre agréable avec un service efficace
pour nos clients et ben alors longue vie
à ce lieu et puis à vous dans ce lieu
j'espère parce que vous en êtes
aujourd'hui puis de 20 ans l'âme
merci merci beaucoup jean luc labrecque
à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]